Oh
always going to be the celebrity friends
at one-half seven right okay so lead as
well and it's fun see it's a possibility
some 102 in that dark and even let show
that you go receive girls they're not
with me know Beason if your check
details out of our minds
with me
say capsule m3 you got you got hard
copies for sodium and you're stepping
yeah the bunch of the fans are under
complete full sets with the denver at
the back
no it's just me I'm afraid no one of
them in turn into assignment that's what
emotions you will need to declare that
as personal as a long
we interest remember her pants okay
thank you
fridges
Oh
just
when the first year
for that
absolute
yes
good evening ladies and gentlemen
officers and members I'll just read out
the emergency evacuation announced well
shouldn't we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the nearest available exit
to the jaina our assembly point will be
in the public car park at side of the
Civic sweet please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded hey can I
am to ask the members and everybody
turns their mobiles off or put on silent
please terms before we get started is it
just going to turn those fronts at the
lights off directly image verily
ok
welcome to this made another development
committee members of the public are
reminded that this is an official
council meeting for the item before us
will be debated according to the usual
council rules apply to council meetings
to which the public are admitted members
of the public are not permitted to speak
at this anything unless they had
previously registered to speak with men
services in this way everyone present
will be able to hear the debate and
counselors will be able to make an
important decision dendrites and what
apologies for absence have been received
in the office from Council of black
cancer griffing cancer Christine Mason
counseling seashore a council of noon
are there any other apologies for
absence can I move the council David
Merrick acts as vice chair for this
meeting so we're looking at it from okay
is that everybody agreed that
Denver ottoman sue cancel out zone will
be such juniper council of black council
music good English substituting for
council briefing councillor michael
jolla will be substituting for
councillor Christine Mason councilman
Williams is substituting for counselor
mrs. Shaw and councillor Smith is
substituting for council middle are
there any other substitute members
please substituting for black but did
say they can do but I did say that I was
building the pug face [ __ ] are there any
other 32 members fight and pray are
there any non members attending close
Lucas kill thanks for the push button
Thank You Alton for your members agree
the minutes of the meeting held on the
twenty-fourth of may 2016 bottom 6th
application land west of out road and
north for growth Watson so yeah
decorators Venus anybody but which have
been a member or what's a pelvic
wald members counselor market mark might
notice kill counselor Mike Steptoe and
counselor Arthur rooms Mike strengths
will present the opposite support this
site we can notice it on the image here
and on the northern side of all road the
full extent of the site that's planning
issue is the overall cycles of all di
Nikita combination of blue in the red
but what interests us tonight is this
part in the white what you can see
ghosting through underneath there is the
layout we've already agreed because this
is a former outline application prior to
that language released from the
greenbelt it obtained outline permission
as you can see in your report and then
more recently reserve matters 293
dwellings to be under construction as we
speak and what's before you tonight is
the balance of the six hundred three
hundred seven units which are proposed
in this area here this island that you
can see at the top here that's the
school site which and some members would
be aware is also part of the audible
development scheme if we could go to the
next
just before we go to some other details
we come back to this layout but a better
image that was before you tonight is
this detailed liar what you see in the
color here the dwellings themselves off
the roads linking in with the earlier
phase and then the landscaped area which
is the very western edge and your
seasons of landscape strip between the
edge of the burden and I'm on line which
runs through here members if they're
getting their barriers and just see the
railway line just off the edge there and
road properties this vicinity here or
Robo Road existing properties finishing
man about here and then open land
obviously there is a footpath link
through the earlier phase of the
development that means I'm going through
to the foot bath then continues across
to Cherry Orchard country park now if we
could go to the typology science plays a
significant backgrounds in the outline
permission was that we didn't want to
get 600 of you like like houses we're
all built in the same brick uniformity
and boring and the intention was to
establish character streets as you can
see here what I'd like to do before we
go through the details to take you
through each street so that members you
can understand at least detailed stage
we're looking at it as you go through
one string you walk into another you get
a different perception you might
actually see the same house type in
terms of the overall box white room
sizes but the appearance the building
will be very different you'll have seen
from the report there's some when we
first had it 19 house heights that
you'll see from the addendum there's
been a further a single house hi Patti
so there is 20 house types that there
are many variations a bit like if you
buy a car and then you hear a different
trim they're all so what you've got with
19 like basic chassis but with
conversations depending on what part of
the colors that you see under nation the
best way I showing you this is to cover
up the overall finished site and I'll
now take you through the first character
area as you can see this is character
typology ie which is the entrance
earrings into the scientist to one in
the previous state around the to drive
Junction he's being built remembers a
familiar in this space though the
roundabout was built I was approved
under the existing details this part of
the layout sorry this part that I out
leads you off around out here so for
consideration tonight's this frontage of
apartheid he was in the previous part I
in the earlier reserve matters and will
see the things that were taken it's
important to get some local distinction
between the new buildings and shall see
as the typical examples of which below
piously there's a mix of two and a half
storey rooms in the roof and two storage
legs and you'll see they've picked up
things from there is around Rochford
most of these are thinking Rochford town
center east street and Western Western
if we go to the next one here you see
the artist's impression as you driving
to the area I think this is the T road
junction under construction the kind of
form and formality tree-lined streets
roads in the middle pavement behind the
virgin for gifts of the dwellers the new
members are a taste the concepts that
have been employed within it a try and
then we go through a similar exercise of
area B or C this town needs the main
entrance road goes through onto the
spyro which forms a use of purple bit
which will come to through the estate
back down to the other entrance areas
and as we look at these are going things
picked up some slight changes you'll see
there's a inclusion hear of an
interesting detail inspired the
architect from ashington heights your
city uses more weather boarding blending
throat and typical architectural details
in the right hand side
spring which has been recorded interview
individual designs if we then finish on
a perspective again to give you an idea
obviously in the rocks that you'll see
that the bikes I'm kind of paving
because this is computer generated these
are actually the images of other
structures or surfaces in the street
then go to the typology see which
follows the spine around to think with
the access under construction will note
from the poems frame the elevations are
like a terrace for okay increasing site
density something changes in the
architectural finishes between four
images on the right and you'll see some
slightly different sources of the
detailing on around rocks trove of
mostly from the west street and south
three areas and here we see a different
perspective of this character here but
members will see hopefully what's come
out through this is a difference in
architectural style and treatment from
the terrors that you've seen already if
we go to character F you'll see this
area is more higher density in the
middle part of the site the game taking
things from Rochford you'll see the
typical elevations of the buildings in
the group at the bottom single pot
chimneys see suddenly appear you'll get
the variation in treatment and services
as well as Lane scoping and we've got an
image here again now character G what
interests us tonight is this area
actually at the top character judy was
the access it runs through footpath and
thus wire through the sides to the
football team through there we are
looking at this top part the drainage
lagoons have already been built to
approved
the early amazed that we're looking at
in house types that go on that part
you'll see the slight density and
spacing changes all in the courts with
the council standard but the architects
approach has been to vary those to
introduce character forms link to our
carriages go back a bit big click a B
they're different forms and roof lines
hopefully members are now getting
impressions in the introductory of hip
roofings that we end unit the far right
we're getting impression that as you've
gone through this estate slowly you're
going to different parts of you going to
demonstrates your arriving in a
different place now it's only one small
area by most of either on the haul road
frontage in this vicinity was approved
in here if they got a little bit of I
around about Junction you see these
house types are inspired by the existing
development transport rather those are
the six images you see on the top of the
plan some different ideas in gates two
driveways two houses bay windows the
features here and at the bottom we see
typical house types in a city conclusion
of larger two-and-a-half story we called
with the Boeing two-story room to the
roof as a typical examples of the
elevational treatment again the typology
schematic
if we look at the area j 1 just two to
go just this area in the two greens Jay
one is an area that faces out of the
site on to the landscaped area where you
see the j1 but what interests us in the
buildings that are east of the red dot
if we go on to the next you see typical
typology is one of interest is these
house types here which have upstairs
lounges and balconies overlooking at
landscaped area they have ground floor
accommodation that all side the bedrooms
of one party wing of the building is a
decent-sized upstairs now and about me
that have done over the neighbors are
overlooked you joining track and then
the landscaping beyond you'll see the
things that they're taken again this
time moved into the areas of mornington
Avenue as well as parts of Rochester you
see an image of 3d form what they would
look like lastly a similar approach out
of looking to the area of the whole name
to the north you'll see again
inspiration of the idea of detailing
ashington heights features again as well
as haul road and Samaria north street to
see the baby windows in the use of
weather boarding and you'll see these
typical house types on the bottom here
Daniel notice the spacing between
buildings as they sort of lead into the
countryside as it were from the high
densities in the middle MC a schematic
of us
that's that we can switch to the street
simply you can separate PowerPoint far
it's just two of those if you can zoom
it as best we can that the top image
shows the character I that's the these
are the ones that front or rather the to
the other side of the roundabout that we
saw then this one down these typology j1
this is the area looking out over the
landscaped area on the western edge a
little bit of their that stop you
remember the road the blue area curled
round to junction of that and then in
the third image is typology I this is
the street to the fronts the y-axis
driving off the roundabout this is the
character affair in the central area the
rent that we saw in the middle of the
plane with a little bit of eye on the
top where it connects the top image is
the spine road running through the cycle
called typology be and then in the
middle is typology James who this is the
area that fronts the final name boundary
and the open space available between
that and yet extend to time alone
yourself and then in the third image
it's the GAR is in the northeast corner
and
and that see the images that has melted
straight things forward now on we can go
to the 25th of my 85 those members will
see from pastry to addendum that the
applicant has revised the cluster of the
affordable housing factor far in one of
the possible
as a top it's a third plan from the
bottom it says I tell you what question
if we can jump to the face to bring
their backs and powerpoint to jump too
many miles to play what's what's
happened chairman is that the
this area here has been subject to
concern expressed by by residents yeah I
think I was inside this area here was
Phillipe affordable housing what the
applicants have done they've taken out
four plots of the affordable housing
which actually amounted to five because
one was a upstairs flattened out his
family seyla no agreement and
redistributed and over here and who dis
are my four plots of private owned
housing and the city details about our
in the addendum the application is
changed to how it was originally written
up by officers a couple weeks or so ago
in that time the applicants have a look
again at the representations made and a
spell effect could make that change to
those more plots now that's what's
before members tonight it's a menu
format the private housing age now fully
along this particle size there is still
a block of affordable housing in sight
sight and your see from representations
that have been received since the
revision bonding I broke residents
association that they feel that the
whole rock should have been
redistributed but officers consider that
the plan that we trying to reach all
showed you the clustering about the
developing these acceptable in planning
terms and that it's really the if you
like applicants the advocates goodwill
to say we make do something to change
that is not a technical requirement
under planning as the
Cashin was originally before when the
report was written he stood the test of
your policies and general planning
guidance but that's a change that the
applicants down there taken up those
amount of four plots that are now
private housing you can see details of
that on the addendum also on the
addendum members will see that the
county of my reality of no objections
arose against the proposal and names
were also simply important the county
highway authority were actively involved
in the design and details proprietor
submission Roger Parish Council have
expressed concern of Lincoln system
downtime preventing pocket of unity the
application details as member who
realize we have had a delay in bringing
this equal to those that hopefully there
has even people time to view the plans
new melodies how in common if they wish
there was received at the county
education Authority we should ensure
that those emergency access to school
site now the difficulty we have is
school details aren't seen that they may
were actually constitute a county
council application in their own right
which will be a consultative but the
framework of the outline application
emits access points that there is
another cited we can wear a condition
and you'll see that we're recommending
an additional condition because this
land is part of the application site we
can justify condition to require the
submission of details when these details
of known because the
county highway the county education
Authority may not serve notice on the
applicant they want the school to a
hundred or so up buildings are occupied
so be sometime in the future before the
detailed design to none but the details
can be submitted and considered to cut
to gain access off the farm track that
is retained alongside the landscaping
area through the computer school access
to maintain the playing field an
emergency firefighting on the playing
field if they wish to do so so very mind
those two additional heads of conditions
general one by the highway authority to
do the road surfaces and the education
authorities requirement for the access
details the recommendation is approved
with subject to those additional pets
conditions beyond on the identity and
suppose that also set out in the report
thank you there are no speakers covering
speakers for other any non members of
the committee would like to speak are
there any committee members with nice
kazakhstan will be concerned as to the
if you like the discharge reported to
the site from the site and objects can
come off the side so much has it what
book what's in them in that jewelry for
balancing the offensive or violent or
something off any German the outline
applications covered by flood risk
accessible considered the driving
strategy and the first fights grief the
drainage details across the main website
though he needed to do that because
obviously to build things affected ranks
this way that works is to balancing
ponds at the same there are drainage
swirls which are lower ways so that in
dry weather they would feel I puddle or
fill up in sorry wet weather they was
puddle or fill up in excessive rain
boots but in trying whether they would
be dry the balancing ponds are expected
to be with most of the time there's a
drainage swell running through here as
well as all the piping and oversized
piping that you're getting schemes where
by then water is held back the basic
concept is that the green field is it
was has a certain discharge rate of so
many meters per second that can't
remember what
what's but the architects and designers
then have to say like we take this
amount which is the discharge and we
have to design a drainage strategy for
the whole site that means that when the
development is built the discharge write
is either the Sun or better and in this
case the arrangements that were makin
inside give a slight uptick which
pleased the environment agency type
members will know that now the matter is
largely dealt with by the Oakland County
Council sustain a drainage do you
remember that when this is dealt with an
outline the environment agency so the
designers will actually improve the
discharge slightly gonna come to you or
what about their requirement us we've
achieved the current discharge rate or
better and they better do that's the
scheme as being the site isn't any
foundations currently being like they're
putting all the roads very vital things
they need to do to do with first days
nope you lead on to this one above it
became that well partially it's just
what concerns me most is that if your
club policy ponds in that corner there
where where you've got the private
housing fee and you have to discharge
into that and the construction of that
oats in pond worries me slightly because
of the air that's going to be taken up
with the excessive water especially as
it right as we know if the swells are
not constructed correcting
in the rider it's the height of money to
the other they will fill up even some
time and I'll get waivers which the
ground is set on firm of disorder it is
a London club and it's very difficult to
get away a nice race that these matters
of cuddling were dealt with that the
outline yes so where we are today is
that there's much to be resolved with
those nice is being put in front of the
gun agency who then deal with it and the
flood risk as know it is knowable dealt
with an inch of engineered correctly
obviously it's processed to check that
song in place and we obviously will
check that but the efficient forward is
reserved notice to do detail I'm not
those issues other in the community
members who'd like to speak on this
application Kevin Smith ok to two
separate forms but in one point of time
just with it within the addendum was
there's quite a lot of information about
national space standards so strange
didn't really go into much detail on
that could I just have a brief resume
made on that every place in future um
you remember that policy dm4 which is
your adopted you don't control
took up the mantle that was missing
we've changes of building rates about
need for roots reassert site and shortly
after we adopted in 2014 the government
standardized it to last avoid fun
council having a view that a bedroom
should be a certain floor space and over
there edging out of council having a
different view and designers of nowhere
to stand etc now what the government
said was that where a council like
ourselves has a policy then we should
follow the National diamonds where a
council right I think perhaps a penny
doesn't have a policy there no space
standards apply now I've set out in a
table there the 20 house types giving
you a comment beneath that table which
shows that most of the house lights
you'll see where they file they fired on
storage space yet the actual gross
requirements isn't is far in excess with
the exception of the nettle house
lighting been introduced which is 1
square meters short of the Christ
you'll see this half times there that
are larger in roseville space than the
government's minimum size to start but
as a consequence of the layout of the
room sizes some of them for instance in
the acetal bedroom seven and a half
square meters midland they can only
achieve in 22 house lights affecting
subs 24 of the 307th well they can only
make only chamber third fourth bedroom
and five square meters in area now
you'll see from the comment below
perhaps not much we can do about that
partly the house types were agreed in
yoga fighters anyway but also the
designing put that went into these goes
back to point out where we had to agree
a design brief to the site and now these
details that are before you are some 23
years later on from there and they post
date the gums national standards so
you'll see that the comment that we feel
is that whilst these 24 have slightly
undersized bedrooms as there were big
ugly the traditional bathroom or small
child room it'd have to be unreasonable
to to ask the applicants go back and
revise those house title because they've
been working on standards that were
required when they got the outline
decision that they then worked up to the
first detail did the design berean for
that and this application now keeps that
character and that design color so the
short for domi effects 24 307 weddings
before they had a single bedroom but
instead of being seven and a half meters
in area is only five on that
case of that one particular room in the
house just looking at landscaping issues
from the diagrams that very clearly that
the landscaping is an important part of
the mature aspect of this side where
happens there's description of a variety
of native Native styles of trees and so
on but I'm just looking for reassurance
that the within the development not in
the part of errors that the native
styles are going to be complying with
the the nature of growth that they have
because although where we love trees
within this area we do know that there's
that there's a particular target area
London play that doesn't turn up
pavement so much whereas some of the
native trees do turn up pavements there
cause root damage it and so on I'm just
looking for reassurance that those sort
of longer-term issues are considered
within this rather than just being a
planting scheme that is going to look
good hm the capsules or a culture
officers studied the landscaping scheme
details which we have don't actually go
into the private garden areas of the
past but they're very much concentrated
on the streets and giving a different
feel as you go from strength to strength
so where the houses are set back
different species that were a culture
says do well in that location have been
selected and where the build forms are
perhaps closer to the pavement there's
more emphasis on small hedges and shrubs
so that they will do well in those more
limited routing areas but all the
species that are chosen as he told me
that wouldn't win an overall design that
their species that would do very well in
those environments that are suited to
the position they're cited in next
resort car parking areas or next two
houses they will chose that as well as
being native to the environment that we
created in other words there's probably
nobody regard stick a big willow or
something in a front garden that's going
to uproot the house or poplars and
things like this the properties of
everywhere branches off everywhere it's
been worth or towns so I think name is
can be reassured that and receive as a
condition of the recommendation that
asked that ensures that this scheme is
improved
give some parent a shin on visitor
parking because it appears in the report
that there's not sufficient parking for
visitors and is it going to end up in a
development group cars park on pain
magnificent major general chaos you
don't expect so check one of the
problems that we have the rooms speaking
with the county highways and offices in
the run-up to submission of details
there's a theory that the site would
become a commuter car part of the
triangle arrived and are therefore not
too far away and they one sees the
design to encourage people not to park
on the street as it were as if his bus
route through the middle of the site
they wanted to make sure that if they
provide you the visitor spaces that one
other counties that you would get casual
parking for a day from commuters around
and put down traffic orders and signage
and WLAN items and antifreeze episode we
need to do this at the design stage now
you'll see from the addendum that the
county highway Rosie hasn't objected to
the amount or lack of visitor parking
that I've set out for you call that is
that is deliberate you'll know that your
parking standards so close to a town
center you're close to alternative
transport options such as royal bastard
on this case
they're the strategy is you don't need
as much parking as if you were say loser
farther out rural irrigator no bus
service at all so when you factor in the
back of car dependency county highway
authority with the trillions of strategy
and the fact that a lot of the houses on
here have visitor parking as well as the
park in the two spaces are more they
would require County highways do not
wish to see areas in the layer that
would be given over to a free-for-all
for car parking so they don't wish us to
go back to the development so you can
provide for visitor unallocated carpet
so
in the end case of visitor parking and
appreciate what you said but it's proven
taking on a bird's estate in raid which
next to train station that subsequently
after that's been built they like to
have them traffic report all those lands
back side repeaters houses which is
subsequently cause any issues that they
live and where their families have grown
that they can't park outside their own
homes so I don't really agree with the
comments from highways these interesting
members refer to the verticity point in
one example if you use again where there
was a house title on a curve of a rug
that wasn't no possibility to get a
driving in front of the garage and we
have an application to convert that
garage it was controlled by condition to
prevent it means I'm now proposed to
change the use of that garage to have no
car parking at top and it wasn't
important enough in front of the house
on on the curb side because we work the
road code and members will now at the
birds estate next to Rayleigh
translation similar distance because
this we reduce planning permission for
that the owner went to appeal and he won
his appealed planning inspector granted
him permission to convert his guarantee
new hardly room for a motorbike to park
on the plot now that's the point that
your parking standards and strategy and
whether County authority on is that
where you're close to a town center you
don't need so many car parking spaces
the public car parks or people don't
have so many cars because of
availability of services and transport
options so whilst I said we were saying
in reality people will park on the
drives want to go to work the reality is
that it's difficult for us as a planning
authority between a location like this
to insist on the extra provision
wouldn't get any support I feel on
appeals we look at example in garage
conversion on exactly you mentioned as
our way Thank You Jenny but I'm tossing
some questions around the football
housing I understand the project of
pepper pot again clustering and I
understand that housing providers like
two plus the more the penalty lo que
plotting is more desirable and I would
be concerned that the clusters appear to
be quite large can you indicate on the
map for members where they clusters will
be sorry thank you I'll have a going
chairman we do have a planet we can't
retreat from shogunate little bit what
the cluster areas like fun remembering
who in the early phases piece of acidity
hear more in this part there's another
area of thinking here Sarah up their
mother area around there if anybody
familiar with a plant c4 houses we've
moved on the affordable housing there is
600 dwellings overall you can't see all
the detail layouts in the white on there
there is 210 affordable units that
chords with with your policy and it be
roots in a way the council's housing
manager acceptable with I think on the
Pepperpot in question I think the idea
was that you wouldn't get alternative
looking buildings in a place on the site
shoved in the corner so how it used to
be done 10 to 15 years ago I think that
this scheme members can be comforted
that where the houses exist in finishing
the same materials to the rest it in the
street so architectural II the hope is
that you wouldn't be able to distinguish
between the affordable units and prime
of the onions or otherwise units that
idea of pepper pot he was the disperse
affordable housing amongst the light out
whereas in this case the clusters that
we have will be designed such that they
were looking for materials that being
employed in the deep zone we went
through they will also feature of the
buildings that will be affordable that
helps check that someone could also so I
have clarity passionate about paragraph
4.26 on page six point one sip easy
that's possible holding the lower input
conditions all that that means that's
where reckon CSS for them council how
the castle county occasions team leaders
recruited we now propose the source of
development subjects that helps
receiving elimination rights as I've
said to warehouse notification
I think conditional support hm it's not
in the conditions recommended because
the deallocate the nomination rights are
and we wrapped up in the outline
application this is the last part is it
were earlier history which are sent out
earlier so will I spoke about dragon age
in my way matters and things like those
those strategies and the nomination
rights report what else do I think there
are causally the group their plan
condition that were partly the green on
the side
anybody else wish to speak hands little
boy
you just go back to comments raised
we've got to traditional parking why
they design it's not allocating space
ball for that issue with a lot of new
developments of this type of design is
that your you're going to get a variety
different people including trade people
who have their own bangs and vehicles
you know much bigger than audrea private
aroun com so is there anything designed
to accommodate like trace vehicles which
what yeah art on sites
German true with most schemes there is
an allocated spaces or oversized or
larger vehicle that can actually find
the space car parking spaces in this
working 30 is your preferred send it was
slightly larger one not only the logic
internal garages at seven or three but
also the parking spaces at five and a
half by 2.9 so no spaces that are
provided are larger they probably
accommodate available for transit day
and things on that on the dryer whereas
in the other areas you have the rolled
out and built to the old 2.4 x 4.8 that
we struggle struggle to do so but
there's no dedicated if you imagine van
parking or delivery vehicle spaces
ladies in this is lame
another question in regard to the
layouts of the the legs open now eastern
any of that so there any trees there
that have any professional goes on
within that area with any of the
landscaping who look like a part of the
original skiing will be completely full
being new chillin the site was a
terrible film so what you have you have
a track running through here with a
small pond that's being retained some
tree grows around it you have I'm old
lady which is unaffected the other side
of the main station strip inside the
site but the longer will row front you
this I think half a dozen oak trees that
are preserved and their retain what the
applicant is doing your seat have
actually taken us all around the
circumference of the tree and cut the ID
thief wedges are perpetrated they killed
the IV and so you can see that some of
those three to go brown or in the top
computing how their doctor that's just
the ivy leaf that he's dying having had
the care to capital idea around the bus
now those trees those oak trees are
being retained in the frontage the dying
Elm that was underneath the gleaning in
a rotor over the cycle path from
sometimes that's all being taken away
and what the applicant will do that
proved under the details to the previous
game is improve this age they're
actually going to plant more like H
lights and struts but if you prove as
well in this all road runs and just
apartment scheme you've got for you
tonight and then they will put up sori
well supports our fence to do some
protection most it establishes and
they've been medically discussions with
the county highway authority about that
because like up here there's a landscape
edge before you get the house in on this
side so the people pathways and things
we'll be near those truths they will be
sufficiently away from the routing
system allowed to establish the preserve
trees that are on the constable road on
adversely affected that the management
has given us phone calls in the office
because people seen and go around the
sword to cut the eye but i think the
phone in the tree understand that we
started the trees are substandard into
the course of the public sure but can
susceptor i guess that job just thought
ghosts 1.4 going on and though comments
about social housing affordable housing
those are familiar with the bright lane
sites it's interesting to now go and
visit that site and it's a bit of a
challenge now to go and identify which
of those properties are the social
housing in the affordable housing they
blend in extremely well and I'd know
quite happy to this going to do the same
I've got happy chairman to move or
propose that we accept the
recommendations of the offices I hope we
get a second
who subjects the amendments the subject
30 second that motion is that we move to
recommend this as as Putin will shout
hands please
thanks Kari
include the business which makes them
thank you for attending the club
Oh
this
contagious
I
yeah like I do
I
panic
Oh
small
ok
yes
development
as you heard notice any of the city some
changes on context we would like to say
can t we must go to my charger times
anyways
okay we have yeah my point is rumored
for my friend electricos if the info
second is not is most authority for
highways respect to the site very much
answer so we can play with on it and
it's very much the same about important
questions are about these examples of
disease they're coordinating w hard time
like some of that site inspections for
they just don't know it doesn't know